look at this image of the biggest
refugee camp in the world it's called
koutu palong it's here in southern
Bangladesh and it's estimated that over
a million people are living here most of
them are rohinga Muslims who used to
live in Myanmar but were forced to flee
out of their country in 2017 when the
military and the citizens burned down
their Villages and drove them out
forcefully so now they live in
Bangladesh in this giant refugee camp
they don't have any status here and it's
not safe to go back to their country
we've been investigating this case and
trying to raise awareness and funds for
these people who made a whole long video
about it over on the channel